nos mémoires du zinc sont consacrés à
arielle dombasle à l'occasion du
spectacle don quichotte contre l'ange
bleu alors c'est une mise en scène de
jérôme savary et arielle dombasle qui
est l'ange plus avant qu'on parle de
cette pièce à quelque chose au moment du
salut j'ai trouvé très mignon c'est
quand jérôme savary dit que vous faisiez
des gâteaux à la troupe est ce que c'est
vrai ça c'est à dire que je nourris un
peu la trouille et comme nous étions
même voilà je suis très une sucrerie la
douceur la douceur la douceur ça ne fait
jamais de mal
alors il ya beaucoup de douceur dans ce
spectacle alors raconté le le propos don
quichotte de la mancha et dansons dans
sa campagne de rêve il voit surgir une
publicité pour le moulin rose avec des
emails et avantageusement présenter la
même quel et dépoitraillés voilà le
dépôt tôlerie et donc en effet cette
femme représente pour lui tout ce qu'il
ne faut pas être lui c'est don quichotte
de la mancha donc le symbole même de
l'homme qui veut un monde vertueux et
qui veut de la noblesse de la rigueur le
bien le beau et tout à coup cette femme
me semble le contraire de ce qu'il faut
donc au lieu d'aller vaincre des moulins
à vent
il part à paris pour essayer de
rencontrer cette femme qui travaille au
moulin rouge
alors on va voir la bande-annonce du
spectacle et après on n'en parle plus
mon ciel désir
ouais
aïe
alors quand on voit cette annonce et
qu'on voit ça varie ici on vous imagine
mal avec savary on a tort je crois parce
que vous avez des filiations ne
serait-ce que de l'autre côté du côté de
la langue espagnole et de l'autre côté
de lui il est argentin et puis il a été
un peu élevés par new york par le jazz
par la nouvelle orléans
c'est vrai qu'on a tous les deux quelque
chose comme arias d'ailleurs on a
procédé la timide à quelque chose
une espèce de fantaisie le goût du
baroque évidemment qui est proprement
d'amérique latine
mais évidemment lui c'est le monde
du cabaret on prend pas de pincettes
c'est les calembours c'est une et c'est
vrai que c'est vraiment le seul à paris
qui arrive à faire cette combinaison
incroyable de music-hall de cabaret de
fable parce que ça a toujours un sens et
pour moi c'est comme faire être dans un
film de fellini cet amour du
saltimbanque cet amour du cirque de la
démesure et surtout cet amour du vrai
champ de la vraie danse et pas du
playback
parce que comme il sait bien des combats
de toute une vie qui est rappelé dans ce
spectacle on change vraiment tous les
soirs et c'est assez difficile parce que
moi j'ai enfin des choses à chanter 30
très divers et kiwis qui demande une
emprise et il faut être athlétique il
faut avoir la forme avec jérôme oui au
six seven est alors de football c'est
aussi l'idée que c'est un sujet
d'actualité qui vous a un petit peu
agacé pour ce que oui oui c'est à dire
j'ai lu comme ça vaguement
comolli a tellement chaque jour
d'actualité mais là du prozac aux
enfants alors j'ai trouvé ça vraiment
significatif d'ailleurs de toute une
époque dans laquelle on vit ou pour un
oui ou pour un non on prend de la chimie
alors bon on peut considérer que quand
on est un adulte
si on leur envie de devenir un espèce de
légume sans affect et ben c'est un choix
why not mais pour les enfants l'idée
qu'un an pour le sang et adolescents qui
est un petit vague à l'âme à l'épave du
prozac
je trouve ça regrettable dombasle
adolescente est ce qu elle a eu besoin
des dt d'escudé moment et j'ai également
absolument mais détestable je déteste
mon adolescence pour moi je ne
l'évoquent jamais c'est une période où
j'étais du malheureux comme les pierres
au mexique j'allais pleurer dans des
champs de caféiers et jeu et toute cette
période mais c'est aussi celle qui m'a
faite c'est à dire qu'on révolte contre
contre tous c'est ce qui a permis que
j'ai pu devenir ensuite ce que je veux
porter tout seul pas d'accompagnement
par des non non non je me suis je m'en
suis sorti avec l'amour de ma grand mère
la nouvelle se pensait pas que
aujourd'hui des parents qui ont beaucoup
de mal avec leurs enfants qui savent pas
trop quoi faire
sûrement bien sûr mais je prends que de
tout temps alors avant il y avait tout
un système disciplinaire qui était
tellement différent les enfants ne
parlait pas à table en effet
on pouvait recevoir des punitions à
l'école en effet moi j'ai été au point
par exemple on météo coin et j'ai eu
aussi on m'a renvoyé de l'école et tout
ça mais c'était des punitions et je n'ai
jamais mûri mérité ces punitions
elle me désespérer mais elle me forget
police vos papiers
voilà c'est un tonton de ses papiers je
sais je pense que vous avez rarement été
contrôlés par arielle dombasle
pour certains oui mais voilà ça c'est
une chose générale observée alors donc
l'occasion dans cette rubrique sifflets
de sortir des articles aux russes sont
pas très agréables quoi pour notre
invité donc arielle dombasle
c'est gravida qui vous appelle alors
vous avez peut-être je n'ai pas lu je
suis là on va écouter c'est d'en lire et
c'était 2 baptiste liger non alors joly
au bout d'un quart d'heure
la chose est entendue l'auteur des
gommes nous offre une série z
d'anthologie ding desous productions
érotiques des années 70 le comique
involontaire n'est jamais loin
une arielle dombasle fantomatique qui
déambulent en robe de voile blanc
derrière des chevaux dialogue et
intrigues aberrant décors et costumes
dignes d'un vieil oss 117 tours
réflexion sur l'art et la violence du
désir comédiens dirigés en dépit du bon
sens c'est gravida qui vous appelle
atteint un haut degré de kitsch qui
ravira les amateurs de second degré
alors ça c'est une critique il faut
prendre au troisième degré moi je trouve
qu'elle est pas mal et puis et puis
robbe grillet vous savez que robbe
grillet c
nouveau roman avec duras avec 900 autres
claude simon et alain robbe grillet
c'est vraiment les immense écrivain qui
ont changé la vision du monde des gens
qui ont changé la littérature qui ont
inventé un style regret a tout de suite
voulu faire du cinéma
dès qu il a fait des films comme durance
d'ailleurs ça a été mais tirer à boulet
rouge alors ce gradiva qui sont dernière
vient d'aller juste ça veut dire quoi
qu'on ne peut pas aujourd'hui être
romancier et s'aventurer dans le domaine
du cinéma sans obligatoirement être
fustigé par l'enquêté ninon panne et ce
n'est pas ce n'est que ce n'est pas une
équation aussi simple mais c'est vrai
que robbe grillet a toujours beaucoup
dérangé car chez lui par exemple dans
ses films comme dans ses romans il n'y a
pas de psychologie
les gens sont très habitués les
personnages et un tant soit peu de
psychologie
non on est des figures on est on est
d'aider des modalités alors on les fait
c'est un pommeau de cinéma totalement
singulière avec l érotisme très prégnant
et avec un érotisme à la robe grillet
c'est à dire que c'est un érotisme
tresses ou ont fait souffrir les jeunes
filles et les plus du côté de ça c'est
sûr et on est plus du côté de ça des
deux batailles que deux
qu'est ce qu'on fait c'est pas un
érotisme soft donc en effet quand on
fait un film d'alain robbe grillet c'est
courageux parce que c'est toujours sur
le fil du rasoir c'est aussi et on sait
vers quoi on va alors ce miroir pour
manifester votre admiration pour qui
alors je manifeste mon l'admiration je
la mets comme ça oh oui vous vous le
donne et je vais je vais le dit alors
qu'on découvre marlene dietrich
alors qu'est ce qui vous fascine chez
marlene dietrich son talent bien sûr
mais dans sa vie cette espèce de mystère
même de l'eau qu'elle avait talent et
oui ce qu'elle avait c'était une
invention de style incroyable c'était
quelqu'un qui aimait paraître mais de la
manière la plus élaborée possible avec
un goût du style le goût notamment par
exemple de l'ambiguïté
oui c'était l'un de ces relations
hommes-femmes la violation de femmes
l'idée de s'habiller en homme l'idée de
cette suprême sophistication avec
toujours un coeur en or c'est à dire que
ce n'est pas la cruelle l'a complètement
auto satisfaite
marlène dietrich quand on lit ça vit
quand on lis les hommes qu'elle a aimés
quand on lit les déboires les tristesses
de sa vie bien on se rend compte que
c'est quelqu'un d'une très grande
humanité
alors il ya d'un côté cette figure
extrêmement sophistiquée et moderne bien
qu'elle soit commune d'habitation 1901
gagnant mal à ramallah et et une liberté
enfin elle a inventé son un style inédit
et elle est devenue un mythe et je
l'admiré et j'aime aussi comme elle
chante elle est devenue un mythe et mais
ce que pensait pas que c'est aussi
beaucoup cette façon qu'elle a eue de
disparaître au monde après avoir été
tant présentes qui a constitué aussi ce
mythe c'est ce mystère autant
probablement vous savez bon maintenant
on est dans une époque où tout est dit
il ya une espèce de transparence on est
partout de tous les côtés c'est très
difficile de disparaître c'est
impossible même mais elle était à une
époque où elle pouvait vraiment
modeler sa vie telle qu'elle n'entendait
et puis il était une très vieille dame
mais qui suivait l'actualité qui étaient
intéressés par tous et
voilà c'est quelqu'un qui reste et dans
la vie jusqu'à la fin alors cette petite
caméra c'est l'idée que vous allez nous
emmener dans un moment de votre intimité
ou de vous souvenir là alors n'est ce
pas c'est marlène dietrich
l'ange bleu qui se retrouve avec
monsieur picouly hélas ici présents
qu'on lui en est ravi alors et c'est un
moyen oui par exemple parce que puis je
ne vois pas pourquoi je dois pas ce
plaisir voilà là où ariel avez vous eu
envie de nous emmener dans quels
souvenirs j'ai toujours l'idée qu'il
faut avoir de grands modèles dans la vie
et que c'est comme ça par une sorte
d'éthique de l'admiration que l'on
arrive à faire ce que l'on veut en
l'admirant les autres et j'ai eu la
chance quand j'avais 16 ans de
rencontrer la callas que ce qu'on a
voulu avenue henri-martin des amis de ma
grand-mère connaissez la kalach tout
simplement et moi j'ai dit mais
j'adorerais l'a rencontré et je me
souviens que je suis allé donc avenue
henri martin et peu
elle était assise dans son salon très
sagement et elle est responsable sur ces
jeunes comme une bonne voie là et ça
m'avait tellement étonné elle était
tellement attentif et moi évidemment je
pensais à tout niveau 6 ni m'aider je
pensais à cette fois extraordinaire et
je pensais que j'allais trouver une fan
tempérament talent qui est calé et elle
était tout le contraire elle était une
femme très posé très attentif très
discrète ravissement
pauli et
et voilà je suis resté une après midi à
part les champs à part les voies et
c'est une chose d'inoubliable
elle m'a dit que j'avais une voix très
vache vous avez chanté devant elle mais
ça elle voulait savoir quelle était
l'étendue de m'avoir ce que j'ai mais
elle s'est intéressée à moi et j'ai
chanté un air de bel canto et elle m'a
dit mais vous savez vous arriverez ce
que vous voulez je vois prévu en tout
cas j'aime beaucoup l'expression éthique
de l'admiration voilà je tourne que
effectivement c'est un domaine dans
lequel il faut soigner son éthique vous
avez raison j'aime beaucoup cette
expression en tout cas merci beaucoup
pour cette recontre avec avec la callas
écoutez ça passe très vite arielle
dombasle
voilà c'était nos mémoires du zinc on a
parlé avec vous à l'occasion de don
quichotte contre l'enjeu oui alors venez
tous puisque la bonne nouvelle c'est que
60 représentations excellent
oui mais voilà ya une trop longue à
cette union ont elles sont
exceptionnelles
voilà donc vous pouvez tous vous rendre
au théâtre de paris
oh vous aurez arielle dombasle et puis
l'ambiance savary c'est toujours assez
extraordinaire et quelques enfants ont
dû faire
et des contorsionnistes et des chanteurs
et des jongleurs et des chevaux sur la
scène enfin voilà et le moulin rose qui
tournait quito qui apparaissait si belle
[Musique]